a lot of people are talking about have
americans become too comfortable
working from home nearly 4 million
americans quit their jobs in april
that's a 20-year
record as some bosses are beginning to
signal
that couch time is over
if you can go to a restaurant in new
york city you can come into the office
if you want to get paid new york crates
you work in new york but labor day
i'll be very disappointed if people
haven't found their way into the office
and then we'll have a different kind of
conversation
yeah well that's pretty clear uh joining
me now kaylee mcinerney outnumbered
co-host and former white house
press secretary and we're so we love
having you here when you are able to
come by you had a busy day kaylee so
thank you
um but you know i this is something that
i think a lot about
this message right that this boss had
the guts to say that a lot of people
don't have the guts to say
like excuse me are you going to a
restaurant are you going to the grocery
store then you can certainly
show up in the workplace that's exactly
right it's just like the tailwind that
president trump put behind our country a
year ago when he stood at the podium i
stood at the podium and said the science
says go back to
school we need our kids in school open
our churches
if there's following the science and
then there's a necessary advocacy that
should follow that
it's time to go back to work it's
healthy to have those meetings it's
healthy to get off zoom and not have
your baby crying and your dog walking in
the background and have these kind of
adult meetings and interactions yeah i
mean everyone understands that it has
been a really difficult year it's not a
question
but it's you know the structure that
used to exist
that allowed people to go to work to go
to the office
um is something that i think you know
we're not hearing enough about from from
the white house at this point and i said
to you in the break
i wonder you know at this point with the
vaccinations so well underway which is
such an enormous success
um what what do you think president
trump would be saying right now would he
be agreeing with this ceo and
how hard would he push on this for
companies to tell people to get back oh
there's
on there's no denying he would be
standing at the podium just like he did
with schools saying go back to work
echoing exactly what you just heard
and by the way let me emphasize the
morgan stanley ceo was compassionate he
said i understand there's child care
issues he was compassionate but at the
same time he recognizes uh that
90 of his company's been vaccinated
that's coming back to work
um what's interesting though is you see
a huge disparity in
texas for example where 50 of people are
back to work versus new york and san
francisco where it's 21
and i think that's fear of covet and
that's where it's the responsibility of
the president president biden to say to
some of these more liberal cities
you can feel but is it real fear or not
because that's his point he's saying
wait are you going out for dinner
right exactly are you going to the
grocery store because why
you know if you are doing those things
if you're you know if you're terrified
and you're hunkered in your apartment
then
you know that that's another issue and
maybe whatever but um
if you are doing going on doing these
things and i'm wondering you know when
you look at competition with china for
example
i mean can we where does what happens to
growth what happens to our nation
if we don't compete at that level
because i don't think that other
countries are going to
china in particular are going to be
operating from that
yes we have to compete at that level
when you have a .001
infection rate in new york city only 158
cases of covid
uh we got to compete with china to your
point and that means showing up for work
getting back to life as usual and
relying on the science that we're
vaccinated and we can have this kind of
interaction you and i are having yeah
you know it's economic condition
competition is going to become more and
more stiff as this thing
um falls to the wayside thank god uh
because that
does appear to be happening and um we
need to remain competitive
kaylee thank you thank you great to join
you